oh my goodness how is this
possible today it's gonna be david
versus goliath we've seen the new
macbook smoke so many machines but you
guys have asked what about amd's best
mobile processors and nvidia's best
mobile graphics card and unlocked rtx
3080 that has full 160 watts of power
well that's what we're doing and we have
this huge 17 inch main gear vector pro
that has some insane specs like 64 gigs
of ram 2 terabytes of ssd and raid 0 a
much bigger chassis with a high-end
cooling solution a huge 230 watt power
brick to feed it all the power that this
machine needs compared to a tiny slim 14
inch macbook pro on battery power
now this machine is so much smaller but
the price tag is not smaller and that's
one thing some of you guys complained
about sure you get killer performance
but this laptop right here costs 4 099
and if you were to get the 16 inch model
that's closer in size uh to this main
gear that would cost four thousand three
hundred dollars and guess what this
machine costs with those specs
two thousand seven hundred dollars and
it has the 17 inch display 1440p 165
hertz so you're definitely getting a lot
of bang for the buck but we're gonna see
how it compares in some popular
benchmarks and real world tests i even
got a few new ones as well that we are
going to add in now before we jump into
that i just want to show you guys the
difference size wise i mean this is just
incredible the macbook is much smaller
obviously it is thinner as well even
though this main gear actually isn't as
thick as i expected but it's definitely
chunkier and of course weight wise my
goodness i mean this thing is so much
chunkier and heavier but it does have
some extra ports for example i like how
the power adapter connects on the back
here of course you can't power this with
usb type-c not enough power but we have
an ethernet connector we have hdmi we
have this usb type-c it does not have a
thunderbolt unfortunately because it is
an amd system we have usb-a ports on one
side
on the other side as well and for some
reason a micro sd card slot when our
macbook has a full sd card slot i'm not
sure why they would put that in such a
big machine now this laptop also has
some cool features like windows hello we
don't have that with our mac apple did
not put that into the notch but you have
touch id to log in and one thing i want
to mention is the macbook you know so
much smaller it does have some
advantages obviously the trackpad the
keyboard the speakers even though it's
much smaller the display
is also 10 bit dci p3 compared to uh
this 17 inch display it's an 8 bit panel
srgb
not the same quality with the high
brightness now if you guys want a full
review on this laptop which has insane
performance specs for the money i will
be putting one out in a little bit later
so make sure you guys subscribe down
below and then with that you guys can
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it but in this video i want to just
focus on performance with this nvidia
3080 with 16 gigs of vram and this cpu
now i want to start out with something
that i'm super curious about personally
something i have not done before and
this is a file unzipping test now that
might seem silly but sometimes you can
wait forever so this is a 16.6 gig file
and when i did this with the intel
machine i mean it was a lot slower and
i'm wondering what amd can do oh gosh
okay all right so i've tried this
multiple times i don't know if it's just
too much tiny files or what it just
keeps crashing on me when i'm trying to
unzip it it takes about three minutes on
the m1 system my other intel system took
about 15 minutes to do it uh yeah well i
guess we're just about to skip this test
i'll just delete that there and let's
move on the other thing i'm very curious
about is the performance of the ssds in
raid 0 compared to apple's fast ssds and
of course performance when we unplug
from the outlets so we're going to test
that next but first i want to press this
turbo button right here there's a
dedicated button on there for the best
performance so there you go we're in
turbo that's the highest end mode to
make sure we max out the performance i'm
gonna use aja to test out since it works
on both mac os and windows it does read
a little bit lower than other
applications but at least it is fair and
take a look at that guys the vector with
raid 0 ssds is faster and write speed
slightly faster but also about 400
megabytes per second slower in read
speeds now as i was downloading the
benchmarking and real world applications
i just saw how quick this machine was in
web browsing it surprised me super
snappy of course plugged in
so what i want to do is run speedometer
and we're gonna see how well this amd
processor this top of line one performs
compared to this m1 max chip which of
course has the same exact performance as
the m1 pro the same 10 core processor
and wow listen to that
the fans actually kicked in
in this web browsing test i don't know
if i've seen that before but it looks
like it's going pretty quick and look at
that we basically have 200 with this amd
system compared to 270 it's still a 40
difference but honestly you don't notice
it now that's practically the same as
the best intel laptop processor but that
intel processor slowed down dramatically
when we unplugged it it was shockingly
bad so let's just go ahead
let's unplug it this will be our first
unplug test we're not gonna do many of
these but i wanna go ahead and see can
we still maintain that really fast
performance and bam look at that i had
my hopes up
and well you guys see for yourselves 152
so it definitely lost about a quarter of
its performance still not bad still a
good score definitely not as bad as
intel so thank you amd uh you guys are
maintaining more performance but this is
also kind of bad news for say some of
the other tests if we do get a
noticeable difference here uh so with
that said let's go ahead and close this
down let's plug that fat barrel plug
back in and test out geekbench 5. so as
you see both of these have 64 gigs of
ram we got the 5900 hx in this main gear
let's go ahead and run that test and i
am using windows 10 on the system that's
because i'm going to be using a script
to fully unlock the 3080 in the system
out of the factory it is locked better
performance than the razer but i want to
make sure we have no limitations at all
and we're going to test that in just a
sec wow this thing is blaring with the
fans
oh
man hopefully that means some great
performance all right guys the results
are in and with fans blazing here is
what we got single core the mac wins by
about 18 that's a great single core
score for the window system multi-core
score we have a difference of 40 percent
now what i'm curious about is will this
performance stick like this when we
unplug it i don't think it will but how
much slower will it be the mac of course
is unplugged on battery power and when
we get into the heavier test not the mix
workload where we have all these
different tests that are being done
what are we gonna get there is the mac
gonna slow down with its limited thermal
system let's go ahead and find out we're
unplugged we're still in turbo mode
we're in the maximum performance on
battery let's run that one more time all
right guys it's a little worse than i
thought i was hoping for a better
single core we have a difference of 50
now from 18
and multi-core instead of 40 faster for
the mac
we are now 95
faster in terms of cpu performance
yeah that's a big difference now i still
want to test the graphics unplugged but
i think as we move forward
i'm not going to be able to test each
test unplugged we're gonna get
drastically worse performance maybe i'll
do one or two unplugged we'll see but
this just shows the ability of this
14-inch mac and the 16-inch to maintain
full performance when it's unplugged
which is amazing that we could do that
it's a portable machine an insanely fast
machine and now let's get into graphics
and just to show you guys i do have the
3080 unlocked here i just ran a test
check out the power draw here 165 watts
164 166.3
that's the full gpu with the gpu memory
of course has 16 gigs the actual just
the gpu chip itself is getting about 130
134
right around there so it's fully
unlocked from the factory um and the
fans were boring so let's do our first
test of just geekbench 5 here because it
will test out a lot of different
computational tasks and bam look at that
performance more than twice as fast for
the windows pc laptop 215 times faster
of course this is a bunch of different
compute tests and as we mentioned before
the mac does it so quick that it doesn't
even ramp up to the full frequency apple
has probably some power saving options
so for if it's a task that's literally a
second it won't give you maximum gp
performance which might be unfortunate
for this test but let's go ahead and
close this down and i'm gonna run gfx
bench which is both optimized for cuda
and metal we're gonna do the off-screen
test because for this one it's not going
to uh change depending on the resolution
so it's gonna be completely fair and our
main gear laptops fans are blazing
listen to this alright guys we have a
result and
sorry 32 core m1 max the rtx has it so
here we have a score of 231
frames per second
with the unlock 3080 an excellent score
compared to 281
that is 14 better performance for the
main gear 3080 laptop
but with that said if you guys watch our
comparison against the 14 and 16 inch
the 16 inch actually performs at 310 so
apple actually under clocked under
volted this m1 max in a 14 inch safe
battery but that's no excuse that's
exactly how it performs compared to this
system here now we also have a
difference in wattage for this 14 inch
we're running at 35 watts compared to
165 watts so that's close to five times
more wattage required to get this
performance so i guess if you look at it
that way it's very impressive what we're
getting and of course we can't forget
this is on battery power so now let's go
ahead and see how these graphics can
perform fully unlocked and no softer
limitations when we unplug it oh my
goodness how is this
possible we just got the results it was
silent the whole time this time instead
of the fans blaring but look at this
difference we have 280.5
on the mac so half an fps difference for
the average in that test but the main
gear
27.9 so let's call it 28 fps
wow
is that why apple when they showed off
their comparison charts they said hey if
we look at the best rtx 3080 that draws
160 watts
when you unplug it the performance is
literally
horrendous uh three times worse than the
mac
now i think this is worse than three
times worse that is crazy and just to
show you guys
we are on the best performance mode we
still got the turbo turned on but does
it really down clock that much when
you're on battery power so i guess i
have to forgive apple for slowing down
the 14 inch compared to the 16 inch uh
just to maintain battery life where this
one
i guess it probably can't even give that
much power from the battery so that's
one thing but then the battery drains so
fast if it's literally drawing five
times more gpu power that's crazy but i
still would like to have a turbo mode
for this mac and now it's time to show
that amd processor some love we're
plugged back in i'm gonna run the
multi-core test i know this thing does
not throttle the fans just kicking
insane loud to keep it cool which is
great that doesn't throttle and the m1
also stays cool so let's go ahead and
see what kind of performance difference
we get when our cpu is maxed out all the
way man i still can't get over how loud
these fans are it's it's incredible take
a listen
all right let's turn that back now the
14-inch you can definitely hear the fans
compared to the 16-inch which stays
silent but at this point
i can't hear them at all and i am
running a 10 minute test i click the not
so let's just go ahead and see what our
final score is going to be i still can't
get over how loud this system is listen
to this
that's crazy but on the plus side even
though we're drawing 60 watts there's no
thermal throttling at all on this system
um we are running at 87 degrees celsius
so it's performing at the maximum which
is great whereas on our mac we're
running at 97 degrees celsius
with our hottest performance core of
course the efficiency cores are running
cooler uh but with that said even at the
end of this test apple still is not
faint running the fans at full blast
they're running them at what maybe 75
right now it starts at about 50 after a
minute and slowly tapers up but they
never max them out they don't want this
to happen with the fan just being insane
on this system technically they could
slow them down a little bit and still
not throttle but they want it to run
cool and man we are finished
this is yeah this is crazy this is very
crazy uh i was not expecting it to be
this close
but we have a result of 12 303 super
consistent with the mac compared to our
previous tests
very very good
compared to
12
182
so yes the amd processor did get beat
by the m1 10 core processor of course we
have eight high performance cores here
two efficiency that barely do anything
compared to eight high performance cores
on this amd
now the performance is right there the
main difference is that this one ran at
60 watts with those super loud fans
and this one runs at 30 watts
to get the same exact performance so
half of the power needed and of course
it's on battery power as well and now
let's get into blender i have splashbox
here i'm going to run the render we saw
that the cpu performance is almost
identical in cinema 4d which is for that
rendering engine but blender's free a
lot of people use it so i'm excited to
see what difference we see now this test
right here you can download a test drone
system but it mostly uses the cpu will
do another graphics test too
but i do want to mention that blender is
not yet optimized for metal so we'll
still run that test but let's see how
these processors compare and bam they're
both done and for the windows pc we have
29.63 seconds compared to
25.62 so so the mac the 14 inch macbook
is roughly 15 16
faster in this test maybe that's the
unified memory kicking in there to help
out now a lot of you guys say hey you
should try out cycles it takes a lot
longer
but it's a better quality render so i'm
going to go ahead and switch over to
that and let's hit render our cpus are
maxed out on both systems and i wanted
to check out their ram usage and the mac
is just using way more ram but take a
look we see 30 gigs of ram used here
compared to only 17.8 both having 64
gigs available now i'm wondering is that
because we're using unified here in the
graphics in those previous tests
they have to share that same amount of
memory whereas here our 3080 has 16 gigs
of its own memory so we'll see if that
goes into effect when we're doing say
video editing and our cycle render is
complete here and the mac wins once
again it took 4 minutes and 12 seconds
compared to 4 minutes and 33 seconds so
about i don't know 21 seconds longer not
a huge percentage difference but it did
still win
using half of the wattage and it's
interesting also the difference in
frequency because the eight high
performance cores here ran basically
four gigahertz compared to the cores on
the mac that ran at three gigahertz so
we have the frequency difference right
there as well by about 25 percent higher
clock speeds now let's give the rtx a
chance i have the party tug project open
you can also download let's see which
one compiles the shaders quicker right
here and then we'll run that graphics
based render bam it looks like the mac
did it here we're about 50 percent as
far as compiling um all the shaders here
so that was pretty quick even though
we're not yet optimized for metal i
think it's going to be another year or
so until it supports it properly but of
course in the meantime people are still
going to be using blender and rendering
and bam the pc laptop just smoke through
that the fans barely started to spin up
and it was done it took four minutes and
seven five so 4.75 seconds compared to
5.95 basically six seconds so 25
faster here
for this render uh which is it's
definitely faster and it's nice and
quick but you would think it'd be a
bigger difference if for example uh in
the other tests we saw a bigger
difference in this and in geekbench for
the overall compute that was about over
twice as fast and we are still plugged
in here so there you go there's that
result and i'm going to do one more test
here um this is going to be a memory
test they both have 64 gigs of ram but i
want to see how fast is the unified
memory compared to
um the standard ddr4 that's in this
system this is going to create a 20
gigabyte file that really tests out the
memory performance and look at that our
memory usage just shot up uh pretty high
and then once it rendered it shot back
down this is a cpu based task so before
slightly slower on the cpu for this
thing but look at this now we have 31.9
basically 32 seconds for that render
with the main gear and 17.76
for the 14 inch macbook that is almost
twice as fast when we combine something
that has a lot of polygons say stuff for
cgi for you know movie studio use when
you really need a lot of memory and
memory bandwidth we see that massive
difference in memory performance with
apple's unified memory and now we are in
lightroom doing some photo editing both
of these are going to perform very
similarly uh looks like when i'm
switching photos surprisingly compared
to the intel systems the amd is taking a
little bit longer so it is lagging
behind slightly i don't know if that's
ram or what that is
but overall zooming in nice and smooth
using brushes
nice and smooth on both slight lag right
when you start it's the same thing on
both of these systems i'm to go ahead
and command undo so as far as the
editing experience of course you have a
better screen here this is a larger
screen but let's go ahead and see our
performance when we export these images
bam we are off we've done this before
against intel systems but i'm curious
how the amd system will compare all
right well i don't know if this is a
fluke
i don't know if it's amd and the memory
i don't know what but our mac is almost
done right here
where this is quite a ways behind bam we
are done
wow we have
two minutes and 12 seconds i guess
that's pretty respectable uh for the
vector pro at 64 gigs of ram amd's best
gpu compared to
one minute and 19 seconds
for the mac i think once again that
unified memory is what's doing it
because the cpu performance under full
load like on cinebench is pretty dang
close
very very close but here we see that
difference that is 67
faster
wow okay well maybe that kind of makes
sense why when we're switching images it
is a little bit slower even though we
have raid zero ssds so that is pretty
pretty crazy and we have david versus
goliath here and so far
david is winning which i guess in the
story it makes sense david wins but
lastly let's go ahead and open up video
editing and we'll see if the rtx can
redeem itself in this laptop that costs
so much less money all right guys now
let's jump into video editing and i'm
just gonna skip the stuff that we know
the mac is gonna defeat the main gear in
obviously on battery power we saw how
slow the graphics card gets insanely
slow we're not gonna test that i don't
even wanna test these easy codecs right
here we know that the m1 max chip has
double encoders and decoders so it's
going to fly through that i just want to
do some tough tests so let's just go to
color um we are going to stabilize this
20 second 4k clip now in the past video
where we did the 16-inch against the
razer the 16-inch was slightly faster
even though the raw graphics a lot
powerful more powerful on the razer just
because of optimizations but here we
have an unlock 3080 compared to
an artificially limited and underclocked
m1 mac so this is going to be
interesting this
main gears 380 should win let's hit
stabilize
start our timer
bam look at that guys wow that was a
crazy difference right there that was
three seconds on the razor to stabilize
it compared to nine seconds three times
faster that is
incredible and i think previously on the
razor it was 10 seconds to do it so i
guess it's just hitting that 165 watts
and because it's done in three seconds
it doesn't heat up fast enough next this
is a 4k
four camera multicam and a 4k project
with luts uh film grain and we have two
clips reversed it looks like as far as
playback we had a little bit of
stuttering on the 3080 at first but now
it's running fine and our mac also is
having no issues now back in the day
this would crash video editing programs
trying out this test looks like our rtx
is running at 61 62 so it's not even
maxing out the graphics and our macbook
looks like to be even less than 50
in order to process this it's
interesting that the mac actually has
more overhead when it has less graphics
processing maybe just efficiency and now
let's step up to a tougher project here
this is 6k blackmagic raw both are
playing it back equally well
and i didn't really want to test uh you
know pro res or whatever we have in
decoders for that or encoding
i just want to throw the toughest raw
stuff at it to test out the rtx so here
we go we have great playback but now
let's go ahead and export this i'm gonna
go and switch it over to mp4 we're gonna
select h.265 that way we can use the
encoders that are built into the rtx i'm
going to select nvidia here it's about
two to three times faster
than using just the software-based
encoding
okay so we got that selected and let's
hit render on this five minute project
and right away both graphics cards are
completely maxed out that looks like
it's our limitation right now i'm really
excited to see these results because in
the past when he tested this uh we had
the 16 inch that has higher clock speeds
more wattage extra graphics performance
and now we're basically doing david
versus goliath the limited one compared
to the unlimited 3080 faster than that
razer and so far it's looking to be
pretty close all right guys we have our
results
and
man
we have two minutes and 21 seconds for
this five minute 6k project uh black
magic raw for the razer compared to a
minute and 53
seconds
that is crazy both limited by the
graphics that just shows you efficiency
with software and even they can have a
lot more raw performance doesn't always
mean it's gonna be faster stabilization
it was a lot faster it was just pure raw
performance now the same exact graphics
in the 16 inch is a minute and 15
seconds a lot faster than the 14 inch
this just shows that this test is
pushing the machines to their limits
that's where we're seeing a big
difference but it still ended up being
beating this rtx laptop
when it's plugged in that is crazy now
you know what i'm gonna do i'm going to
hit render all i'm going to hit
render again
let's let it get started all right it
looks like two minutes remaining two and
a half minutes it's catching up so click
close to what it should be for 217. i
want to see what the products can be
like if i just go ahead and unplug it
right now
what is it going to
change to
i don't know if i'm going to want to
wait that long but i just want to do
this because i did mention to you guys
that uh maybe i'll do that another
unplug test at the end
so it looks like right now so far we're
up to
pretty much five minutes remaining six
minutes remaining now seven minutes
eight minutes remaining you guys
basically get the point of the
performance if you're on battery so this
is it basically a portable desktop you
should treat it as such so what did we
learn
well just like the intro david versus
goliath yes goliath is more powerful
larger heavier cheaper in this case but
when it comes to optimization it's crazy
what this 14 inch can do so thank you
guys for watching click above if you
guys want to subscribe and help us reach
our goal of a million subscribers check
out one of those great videos right over
there if you want the full review make
sure your notifications are enabled this
one max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]